We have defined the conditional
expectation of a
random variable given another
as an abstract object, which
is itself a random variable.
Let us now do something
analogous with the notion of
[the]
conditional variance.
Let us start with the definition
of the variance,
which is the following.
We look at the deviation of the
random variable from its
mean, square it, then take the
average of that quantity.
If we live in a conditional
universe where we are told the
value of some other random
variable, capital Y, then
inside that conditional universe
the variance becomes
the following.
It is defined the same way.
Well, in the conditional
universe, this is the expected
value of X.
So this quantity here is the
deviation of X from its
expected value in that
conditional universe.
We square this quantity, we find
the squared deviation,
and we look at the
expected value of
that squared deviation.
But because we live in a
conditional universe, of
course, this expectation has to
be a conditional one given
the information that
we have available.
So this is nothing but the
ordinary variance, but it's
the variance of the conditional
distribution of
the random variable, capital
X. This is an
equality between numbers.
If I tell you the value of
little y, the conditional
variance is defined
by this particular
quantity, which is a number.
Now, we proceed in the same way
as we proceeded for the
case where we defined the
conditional expectation as a
random variable.
Namely, we think of this
quantity as a function of
little y, and that function can
be now used to define a
random variable.
And that random variable, which
would denote this way,
this is the random variable
which takes this specific
value when capital Y happens
to be equal to little y.
Once we know the value of
capital Y, then this quantity
takes a specific value.
But before we know the value
of capital Y, then this
quantity is not known.
It's random.
It's a random variable.
Let us look at an example to
make this more concrete.
Suppose that Y is a
random variable.
We draw that random variable.
And we're told that conditioned
on the value of
that random variable, X is going
to be uniform on this
particular interval
from 0 to Y.
So if I tell you that capital
Y takes on a specific
numerical value, then the random
variable X is uniform
on the interval from
0 to little y.
A random variable that's uniform
on an interval of
length little y has a variance
that we know what it is.
It's y squared over 12.
So this is an equality
between numbers.
For any specific value of
little y, this is the
numerical value of the
conditional variance.
Let us now change this equality
between numbers into
an abstract equality between
random variables.
The random variable, variance
of X given Y, is a random
variable that takes this
value whenever
capital Y is little y.
But that's the same as
this random variable.
This is a random variable that
takes this value whenever
capital Y happens to be
equal to little y.
So we have defined the
abstract concept of a
conditional variance, similar
to the case of conditional
expectations.
For conditional expectations,
we had the law of iterated
expectations.
That tells us that the
expected value of the
conditional expectation is the
unconditional expectation.
Is it true that the expected
value of the conditional
variance is going to
be the same as the
unconditional variance?
Unfortunately, no.
Things are a little
more complicated.
The unconditional variance is
equal to the expected value of
the conditional variance, but
there is an extra term, that
is, the variance of the
conditional expectation.
The entries here in red are
all random variables.
So the conditional variance has
been defined as a random
variable, so it has an
expectation of its own.
The conditional expectation, as
we have already discussed,
is also a random variable, so it
has a variance of its own.
And by adding those terms, we
get the total variance of the
random variable X.
So what we will do next will
be first to prove this
equality, and then give a number
of examples that are
going to give us some intuition
about what these
terms mean and why this
equality makes sense.